all right people we
are live on the youtube i'm dave rubin
and we've got another friday panel
extravaganza for you
joining me today are the author of why i
couldn't stay silent
david harris jr founder of america's
frontline doctors dr simone gold and
host
of stu does america on blaze tv
stew bergery welcome to the reuben
report everybody
thanks dave thank you dave so glad to be
here i am glad to have you guys i've uh
wanted to have you all on well stu you
were on once before but i wanted to have
uh simone and david on so long overdue
we're gonna do a little recap of the
week and unfortunately
because this is america in 2021 it's a
lot of a lot of race stuff
uh and then of course some kovid stuff
uh let's start though there was a clip
that went viral earlier the week
former president barack obama was being
interviewed
and basically made light of critical
race theory which as we're
live streaming this right now is the
number one trend on twitter
uh but he's not having much of it let's
take a look
i also think that there are certain
right-wing
media venues for example that monetize
and capitalize on stoking the fear and
resentment
of uh a white population that is
witnessing a changing america
and seeing uh demographic changes and
and do everything they can to give
people a sense that
um their way of life is threatened and
that people are trying to take advantage
of them and we're seeing it
right now right where uh you would think
with all the public policy debates that
are taking place right now
that you know the republican party would
be
engaged in a significant debate about
how are we going to deal with the
economy and what are we going to do
about climate change and what are we
going to do about
lo and behold the single most important
issue to them apparently right now is
critical race theory
who knew that that was the threat to our
republic
so it's quite an extraordinary clip
actually because
he's making light of really the set of
ideas that is just running rampant
through the country right now and
destroying all of our institutions
uh harris i have according to my
paperwork here you are black is that
correct
well yeah i'm definitely a member of the
black community but actually like obama
we have white mothers my mother is of
irish descent so while i've never been
accused of being a white person
obviously i'm a part of the black
community the one thing that uh that
stands out to me with obama
is the fact that hey he's trying to
downplay
the attack that's going towards our
children
critical race theory at its very core um
is is absolutely racist it's it's
teaching and wants to teach our kids
to look at other kids around them and
people
adults and judge them based on the color
of their skin
um it's evil it's abhorrent and it
absolutely is a threat to the foundation
of this country because our [ __ ] our
kill
our kids our children are the next
generation they are the bedrock of this
country so let me get you so freaking
downplay like that's disgusting so
you're telling me that we shouldn't be
judging based on the color of skin and
we shouldn't think
think we shouldn't think that things
like being on time
and working hard that those are white
things you mean you're saying that
you mean everyone can do those things
it's quite extraordinary stu
you've been a conservative for a while
he's attacking you republicans
your eyes not on the ball you should be
worried about climate change
yeah i mean this one even more
specifically he's attacking us
he has made those comments in the
context of the police acted stupidly one
of his first controversies as president
and he was talking
quite clearly about all of our friends
here uh mr glenn beck
who after that comment was famously on
fox and friends and
called the president a racist and well
there's things i love about glenn
uh and one of them is uh he will just
kind of come out with it even when he's
not a hundred percent
locked in on exactly what he means you
know he knows he's got a
he's got a great instinct that
something's going on and it sometimes
takes him a while to work through it
one of the reasons he's been so
successful he's in the radio hall of
fame is because he works through that
with the audience often
and what he was feeling out at that
moment was
critical race theory it was this exact
thing
i mean he was criticized for saying oh
well it seems like obama has a problem
with the white culture go back to
obama's book that's those are the exact
words he uses the white culture and now
the white culture
whiteness is evil whiteness is terrible
it's so
commonplace in our everyday discussions
it
it doesn't even stand out i mean he
really was on on the mark on something
there and and he
you know has gone through a long
struggle with that comment but
i think in in general's sense it's been
vindicated pretty strongly i mean what
is
critical race theory except racism right
and the irony of course
is that there are really no white people
i mean i suppose a tiny sliver of sort
of irrelevant people but
no mainstream white people are running
around saying white is better it's the
critical race theory people that in
essence are saying white is better
because it means you're on time and you
work hard and you know that two plus two
equals four
and in effect you don't judge people by
the color of their skin
uh dr gold i know this isn't fully your
your area of expertise um but
critical race theory these ideas they're
leaking into everything i mean we're
seeing them leak into the medical field
into the scientific disciplines
etc what have you seen on that right
i think it's right up our alley face
through the
joystick
and when it starts thinking into the
medical medical arena medical education
you know people have cancer
we don't go for americans although he
suffered
just very family in all of venus
washington state
yeah you know dr gold your audio is
popping in and out a little bit so i'm
not sure if everybody was able to hear
that so we'll we'll run a little test
while i while i throw it back
back to david david do you think we have
the right tools
let's say this this new sort of right
alliance has the right tools
to fight critical race theory
effectively i mean it seems like we've
just seen
everything crumble under the weight of
this
well it is crumbling under the weight of
this and it's just getting started it's
not going to go anywhere anytime soon
and the power that we have
is at the local level the thing that is
uh is very
alarming and should be alarming to every
single viewer watcher
is that there are individuals in the
school boards that are approving
uh this this doctrine that is literally
teaching
racism uh and and in order for us to
literally take back the power
we've got to not only be informed our
the parents in every school district
around this country need to be informed
as to who is making the decisions
on who is on what curriculums are going
to let into their schools
and then they've got to make changes
there's already you know it's it led up
to this i think crt was first originated
in 89 it's been growing for you know a
couple decades and it's reached this
point where now it's kind of
introduct introducing into the
mainstream curriculums of our schools
and being widely accepted and being
approved it sounds like by obama by
dismissing it
the parents of these kids need to get in
their school board meetings find out
what's going on
replace the individuals that are okay
with this kind of doctrine that's the
real power that we've got as parents
waking up getting involved and taking
action now well said i
i do want to note also by the way in
case marigay the new york times
op-ed lady is watching this show that
i'm pretty sure the flag behind
harris is not meant to be a white
supremacist flag i know
she saw some flags on the road she saw
some flags on the
long island expressway it freaked her
out stu we've talked
about this a couple times on your show
but i sort of believe that it's kind of
everyone versus the woke right now that
the conservative ten
in my opinion opinion has become very
wide libertarians
traditional conservatives more religious
conservatives i'm even seeing
some atheists conservatives now that
something really robust
is happening on the right are are you
seeing that
i i totally agree with you and i think
because it's so incredibly
shocking right you know david made a
great point that started back in the
late 80s early 90s
where it rose to sort of an academic uh
prevalence
uh but it was not something we were
talking about it wasn't something we
were thinking about it wasn't something
we were pushing back on
and then all of the sudden it seemed
this just
crazy attitude became the mainstream and
the only acceptable way to go
i mean ibrahim x candy in his book
literally
advocates for discrimination as the only
solution for our past sins he says we
should discriminate i mean that is so
far and away
i think we all thought at least my whole
life i did
that the vision of martin luther king
that basic sort of
idea that we should be treated uh you
know by the color not against the with
the color of her skin but the content of
our character
that merit was the most important thing
that goes back to our founding george
washington had
you know gave out awards for merit this
is something this country has been based
on
forever so the idea that we would just
suddenly jam this in reverse and now
we are required to think about race as
often as richard spencer or david duke
and make
that central in our decision-making
process is so stunning
i think to americans of all stripes that
there's people you know i think
even on the left a good chunk of the
left that are saying i i don't agree
with conservatives on tax policy but
this goes way beyond that
yeah it seems to be far more about
revenge than anything else and it's
actually kind of funny you see those
memes every now and again where they'll
take what a white supremacist
said 20 years ago and and it's basically
the exact same thing
as what the woke left is pushing out all
right dr gold hopefully your audio is a
little bit better can you talk about how
this is related
to health equity i mean we saw even in
certain places
like seattle they were giving out
vaccines first to people
of color you know operation warp speed
was filled with
face language they were saying that they
wanted to do
commercials that they should attract for
black people
that you know
again as a doctor i go with the science
the science shows
people with diabetes people apply sugar
those are the people at high risk
people with multiple comorbid conditions
people in nursing homes those are the
people that should have been prioritized
for back pain it was startling to read
that they thought people of color or
people of color who were attracted
should be doing promotion
it was really shocking i actually felt
like completely racist
and i also found it very expensive when
they keep talking about vaccine
hesitancy
as though that's you know not a real
thing the truth is the government has
done
many many um scientific studies
there's certainly any many others where
black people were harmed
due to vaccines and whites in fact i
know that it'd be sick
measles hepatitis b and so then they
realized it by saying that this is just
quote unquote vaccine
and so black people can't say for
themselves that's fun
very disturbing yeah well we've heard a
lot of stuff like this we've heard joe
biden say
black people apparently don't know how
to get online you ain't black if you
don't vote for him
uh harrison
[Laughter]
i've been in business i was 20. i just
yeah joe biden's definition of black eye
in it
i mean does joe biden know that there
are black accountants and lawyers but
all right but put that aside it's
actually
the the right segue what uh dr gold said
there to sort of the censorship version
of all of this
because as you guys know i mean you go
on twitter you don't know if you're
seeing stuff that's manipulated or
de-boosted or downgraded we know about
the google algorithms and all that
well twitter their official at policy
account
they put out probably the most ironic
tweet in the history
of the world although every week there's
like a new level of irony that we can
get to
uh this is what they said regarding
nigeria just a few days ago
we are deeply concerned by the blocking
of twitter in nigeria
access to the free and open internet is
an essential human right
in modern society we will work to
restore access for those in nigeria
who rely on twitter to communicate and
connect with the world
hashtag keep it on um now the good
people at twitter as you know have
banned the former president of the
united states they banned
probably about a hundred thousand people
it's hard to get the exact number
uh after the january six events we know
that conservatives are banned all the
time for everything
stu you're still on twitter are you just
not edgy enough what's going on
apparently not apparently not um first
of all we should point out that twitter
is not a human right it is a human
punishment
yeah it is a scourge on all of our souls
[Laughter]
it's the equivalent of being struck by
lightning uh it is uh
i mean look twitter is obviously a way
that we all
uh you communicate at least in the in
the hyper political sort of realm and
uh you know the the instinct here of
course is right people should be able to
say
what they want to say what of course as
you point out is the real issue here is
the
just unmitigated undefense
defensible hypocrisy of these types of
statements
twitter is it has done the opposite of
what they're claiming uh to do
and they constantly push down this road
where they want to have it both ways
where they want to say look we're a free
speech platform and this is what we're
doing we're changing the world we're
making a difference
and at the same time they're shutting
down anything uh that is out of
line with with the basic fact checker
point of the day
and as we've seen this week many of
these get reversed
what happens to those people who lost
their account six months ago a year ago
for something that we now know
is true and the the i guess the the
craziest part about this is twitter
doesn't have to put itself in this
situation right
you know they could easily when when uh
you know uh ayatollah says something bad
on twitter
i don't blame twitter for that i blame
the ayatollah for that right
and so if donald trump says something
they think is bad well then
take it up with donald trump he was the
president of the united states we should
know what he's thinking
if he's saying these terrible things
right they want to control the
experience i think dave
yeah and and they they're completely
making a counter argument because if
it's a human right well i
think that orange man is human amongst
the other people
maybe the orange thing he's not so human
dr gold go ahead
so i don't know people know me as a
doctor but i'm also a lawyer so i really
like this segment so
there's two parts one is i can't wait to
go into court of law and argue for
twitter that twitter's saying that this
is a human right so
that's a fantastic me as a lawyer i love
it
and then the doctor part of me is really
looking forward to the day when doctors
can post
government information such as bears
screenshots for which my colleagues have
been
um d platformed right they'll post a
picture of the vaccine adverse events
reporting system screenshot of the
deaths
and for that they're taken down so as a
lawyer and a doctor i was delighted to
read this wait let's go a little further
with that lawyer part because
basically if their argument is that they
are you know a human right
in effect then they could be in a lot of
hot water by their own words at this
point
when somebody who gets kicked off says
hey you're supposed to be an open
platform right
exactly right i honestly i'm really not
joking i think actual
argument they've already said that this
is they are so fantastic you no longer
have to talk about first amendments
right like oxygen and water and food
harris is it is it a human right i mean
really the truth is and i think this is
sort of what stu is saying like if
twitter blew up tomorrow
if their servers were just completely
decimated i actually think we'd all be a
lot more functional i think it's
probably like
democracy if democracy would be in
better shape i would go on i would smile
more
we'd be okay and by the way we'd figure
out other ways to communicate when they
say human right
it's because they want to keep us on
these things all the time right
yeah they absolutely do it's not a human
right um
it is their way of curating the
truth and the news that they want their
audience you know to to receive i
uh as simone shared i actually did share
a video of uh one of the one of the
senate hearings
in texas where the gentleman speak and
the doctor speaking was sharing
uh the report from vayer's vaccine
adverse event reporting system
on the amount of debts and i left it up
on instagram i left it up on facebook i
posted on twitter
uh i took it down about six hours later
on facebook and twitter uh and instagram
because
they are they're constantly threatening
me to unpublish my pages
yeah and i forgot to take it down on
youtube and youtube gave me a community
strike one more strike and i'm off of
youtube
so it's their way to curate just as
they've done for so many other things
over the last couple years
if what you're saying is not cohesive
with their mainstream media narrative
that they want the people to believe is
the only option for us to think
basically don't think for yourselves
then you're the enemy so yeah
if twitter blew up tomorrow life would
go on and it would probably be a heck of
a lot better for a lot of people
than it is right now i think you all
have to officially join me off the grid
for august you know i lock that phone in
a safe and i'm gone
i'm gonna right before i go off this
year i'm gonna personally invite a few
people publicly
and i think you'll all be on the list
but i'll take the reverse side of this
for a second stu what do you think about
this that if we didn't
have these gatekeepers i'm playing
devil's advocates slightly
if we didn't have these gatekeepers and
everyone could say whatever they want at
all times
that the the truth would even be further
destroyed
because no one would know who to trust
at any level this is not exactly what
what i believe i'm just trying to give
the devil his due here
no i i think that's a it's not a crazy
point you will have
really wrong things be put out there but
that this goes against all of american
history right
american history is we started this
country with
with just people accusing each other of
crazy things and we let the american
people sort it out
i always think more voices are better
than fewer
and we often see this where you know
one side of the argument wants to
control what is allowed in a debate and
at the end of the day
you know is it a human right well you
know no one no human had uh this right
before 2006 so i think it's somewhat
difficult to argue that it's a human
right and as you point out with your
month off
seems to be your happiest month of the
year so i don't know that it's
necessarily a wonderful thing for
everybody
but there is this idea of open and
honest debate
you should be able to say what you
believe and you should be able to have
it be criticized by
others in an open format and if that's
allowed i think the american people wind
up getting to the right place eventually
stu are you telling me i'm looking here
are you telling me that the
uh twitter as a human right was not
guaranteed by the bible or the
constitution
i've been looking for it so far there's
almost no tweets in the bible
somebody got my notes wrong here all
right well that's a good segue to the
third story
about hydroxychloroquine because a lot
of what you've been talking about
really for over a year now dr gold you
and some other doctors who
in most cases were censored uh is
starting to come out to be true so i've
got some quotes here from
yahoo news a new study shows that the
controversial drug hydroxychloroquine
touted by former president donald trump
increased the survival rate
of severely ill coronavirus patients
the observational study published by med
rxiv
found that anti-malarial the
anti-malarial drug hydroxychloroquine
along with zinc
could increase the coronavirus survival
rate by as much as nearly 200 percent
if distributed at higher doses to
ventilated patients with
a severe version of the illness and
finally we found that when
the cumulative doses of two drugs hcq
and azm
were above a certain level patients had
a survival rate
2.9 times the other patients the study
conclusion states now this is some stuff
dr gold that you've been talking about a
few other doctors have been talking
about and i remember when you started
mentioning this
i think around last summer or so we had
a debate with my producers
about having you and some of the other
doctors on the show and we thought all
right well we could
literally just have our channel blow up
and my business completely altered and
everything else and we didn't do it so
i'm glad that you're here now
but uh how are you feeling about a
little a little vindication here
you know maybe listen to me that study
because there was a study this time last
year that came out of detroit showing
that hydrochloroquine was very effective
in henry ford's
detroit hospital and they buried that
story the friday
third and they'd actually be doing that
there's more than 300 scientific studies
that show
promising results any kind of early
treatment
just one particular drug there's
multiple fronts that work this
really beginning the nation of china was
actually using clerk when it's
february 2020 and all over the world
and everywhere france first so um the
disturbing thing to me
this is all the results of a black space
page this entire issue is censorship
if affecting people couldn't hurt both
sides they could have heard the truth in
their darkness
maybe oh god we wouldn't be in this
situation
but one side was very
you know out there's now
tens of thousand positions like myself
tested
nation yeah guys i hope i i hope you're
hearing dr gold a little bit
better than i am it's it's popping in
and out there so i apologize for that
we'll try to clean it up for next time
uh but david jumping off uh what dr gold
just said there
this idea now that you know the lab leak
we can suddenly talk about that we
couldn't talk about that a few weeks ago
you might have got booted
for all those things and the fact that
even yahoo i mean i sourced yahoo here
they're even giving trump credit for
talking about this literally over a year
ago
it seems like everything we're not
allowed to talk about three months ago
becomes true three months later
yeah all the conspiracy theories are uh
being proven true it's like we don't
have any more because they're all coming
true
you know i was somebody that was uh
slammed on all big tech from facebook to
instagram to twitter for
talking about hydroxychloroquine and
trying to share with the american people
uh the potential benefits that sounds
like are now being proven and brought to
light
and i really hope that it's just
absolutely pissing i hope i can say that
but pissing americans off
at what's taking place right now it's
going to get me taken out
[Laughter]
yeah probably won't be but you know what
for for for
this country to have gone through what
we've just gone through
to be pushing this towards getting the
jab
falchi's now talking about by the end of
the year we'll have kids as young as two
years old
getting the jab instead of falci talking
about or any
anybody from the science and doctor
world part of biden's current
administration or whatever the task
force is called now talk about anything
that to
remedy uh the effects and the detriment
of of
contracting covid they're just pushing
this jab i mean to me
it's like i really believe there's
something a lot larger at stake here
there's something a lot bigger taking
place
uh because it seems like a very
coordinated effort from big tech
from the swamp creatures like fauci that
were giving donald trump uh
you know his opinions on what should
take place to silencing voices
talking about any alternative to uh to
benefit the people
and we've lived through an absolute
catastrophe i mean it's so many people
are gone
people have died uh people have lost
family members couldn't visit their
family members members in hospitals or
in old folks homes
uh it's absolute travesty probably it'll
go down to one of the worst things that
ever happened in this country
and it was avoidable and i really hope
americans are getting pissed off
yeah i think i think they're yeah dr
gold go ahead i i have to jump in
because we outlined it you probably
don't know but hot off the press
yesterday america's frontline doctors
filed a very severe
serious lawsuit in the 11th district in
alabama
and we outlined the entire thing we
outline the collusion that's gone on the
censorship that's gone on
the lack of access to early treatment
we've named
names about people with conflict of
interest you can find that on page 94
96 in the complaint it's all there we've
laid out the whole case for the american
people to see
and you can find it on our website
americas.org you can find it on our
website
okay we'll we'll add the link to that in
the description below so people can find
it but let me let me ask you one other
thing before i get stu which is
in terms of fouchy you know i've been
pretty critical of him i i wasn't for a
long time because i was just
trying to listen like everybody else and
i'm not the expert but after this email
leak where we literally hear him saying
to p to a friend of his who asked him
about masks oh well
in effect masks don't work the mask that
you buy at the store while at the same
time basically that week
he's telling people oh maybe double mask
like do you
what level of credit or or trust should
we have in him at this point
you should have none we have thousands
of flip-flops on our website where we
outline the flip-flops that he makes on
a weekly basis he reverses himself
he's a political animal i like you did
not size him happily in the beginning
i've watched i've waited he he's double
talked he's like a politician
and it's really really harm the american
people turn people across the world
he's really culpable for a lot of deaths
we've outlined it very clearly
in the lawsuit and we hope that him and
others are held back
stu i know you could do a good star wars
reference i mean he literally said a day
or two ago that an attack on him is
attack on science which is very
palpatine i am the same
kind of thing beyond doing your show
when you're doing glenn's radio show
you know a couple hours a day you guys
do four hours a day is that fourth uh
yeah three on radio and then one on tv
right so four hours a day and you've got
to cover this stuff and also be worried
about not getting booted off
everything how have you tried to
navigate what you're allowed to talk
about here
well you know i mean i think it's funny
because you look at i think it's one of
the strangest things of the past year
and it's been a really freaking weird
year
but the idea that a medicine could
become a
partisan issue is such a strange concept
it's like you're talking about medicine
you want r d to stand for research and
development not republicans and
democrats
um so it's one of those things where
like we
you know you should you should be able
to do these things if you want to do
them you know it's like freedom is
always the answer you know i'm i'm
probably more pro of the vaccines than a
lot of people are in the audience
i think they've you know i think it's
performed pretty well so far and i'm
glad operation warp speed existed and
i'm
glad we're seeing the end of this i hope
on the other side of that there's a lot
of people who disagree with me
they shouldn't be forced to take them
like they shouldn't be pulled off the
market for me to take them
it's so it's so interesting that on our
side of the aisle
these conversations are easy because the
answer is always freedom
you choose what you choose i choose what
i choose it makes america great we live
with the consequences and we go
on it's hard to navigate i think when
you get into this idea
of big tech because you never know where
they're going to crack down you don't
know what they're going to
what what thing you say is going to get
you kicked off and you know the dave
rubin channel
is going to be gone all you can do is be
honest and talk about what you believe
and you know and try to understand that
there is some
uncertainty on some of these things uh
but at the end of the day you're not
going to be able to please mark
zuckerberg you're not going to be able
to please jack they're going to do what
they do
we better make our own places to go as
well so we can get this information out
which is what we try to do with blaze tv
yeah stu sounds like you want to kill
grandma i got it okay
yeah uh doctor i got a shirt for you
brother
doctor can you just talk about the uh
the vaccine in general for the for the
people that are maybe on the fence right
now
what information would you want them to
know about the vaccine
or the vaccines i should say are you
asking me dave
yeah yeah yeah so i agree completely
that this is a free
choice one of the things we're seeing
going wrong is that there's not
voluntary
informed consent and consent
overwhelmingly does not exist
you may have gotten it but
overwhelmingly people are not getting
information people don't understand that
this is experimental
and it's clearly moving away from being
voluntary when we see governors of
various states offered free money free
scholarships free ice creams
local municipalities pay the 12 year
olds can consent without their parents
consent or knowledge we're talking about
treading into very uh
you know involuntary territory that's
our concern
is the fact that it needs to be followed
it needs to be informed people need to
hold this experimental
and to be true and
from foreign you can't be giving
children experimental medication
we're literally treating american
children like those this has never
happened
it's terrible yeah uh harris i'm going
to give you the last word here going
going off that i mean freedom are we
going to keep it or are we just
throwing it away bring us home with that
scary american flag behind it
we yeah yeah me the racist uh we need to
keep freedom as the main choice we need
to keep it
uh as we need to champion it is what we
need to do i was in new york city last
week
walking through central park with a
t-shirt that i had designed that i was
hoping liberals would love
here it is dave i saw it a little higher
yeah yeah that's good
my body my choice that is what it should
all be about it's our decision people
are being forced to get the jab
people are being threatened with their
jobs or livelihoods if they don't get
the jab it
the phrase fits in this narrative which
if you like that shirt you can get it at
davidharrisjunior.store
but people should not be forced
especially when all these vaccine
companies
have complete uh and have complete
uh there's no no potential for
repercussions they can't be sued if
anything goes wrong
and we're not being told exactly what it
what the damages are from bears
uh that information is not out there so
we need to champion freedom
uh we need to wear whatever we're gonna
wear proudly to show americans what we
believe we need to take action
we need to get involved at the local
level and we need to make sure that we
take this country back from the
progressives
uh leftists that are trying to just push
socialism and communism literally
on our children and on the rest of us we
got to stand up and do what's right dave
excellent closing statement my friend
well i thank the through you for doing
the show
uh dr goldberg are going to link to that
case right down below the website
uh thank you guys i'm gonna i'm gonna
finish up with a little monologue of my
own but you guys are now free to
enjoy your weekend so thanks for joining
me thank you dave
thanks happy brother yeah my pleasure my
pleasure thank you guys
uh guys i wanted to finish up this week
well first off i should tell you because
i know a whole bunch of you have been
asking me on social media i did have
part one of a root canal yesterday an
emergency root canal
i was in a lot of pain during the show
yesterday but somehow managed to pull it
off but my face was like ready to
explode
so i got something they drilled in they
did something
it's like a two or three part uh
procedure but i'm gonna be okay the
pressure
has been relieved i will survive and i
ate a big steak last night so i was even
able to chew so there you go on that
um my main takeaway of the week putting
aside all of these stories is really
what happened
uh at long island's nassau coliseum a
couple days ago that we covered
uh with nikki revive the the singer
songwriter
singing the national anthem and
basically you know sort of putting the
microphone down and letting those
thousands of people
uh in nassau coliseum sing the national
anthem how absolutely moving it was i
mean when i said on the show
that i got chills up my spine watching
it i was not kidding i was not being
sarcastic or hyperbolic my guys in the
studio here
said the exact same thing my assistant
uh texted me right after saying she got
chills up her spine and then i did go
into the youtube comments
and i looked and tons of you said the
exact same thing
that is literally guys our bodies
sending us a message
about what is true and what is good and
what is right and what is just
that that's the spirit we need to take
this thing back
uh as you know if you watch the show
earlier in the week
i grew up 15 20 minutes barely from
nassau coliseum i went to many islanders
games there
games there over the year i went to wwe
i think i was at a wrestlemania event
there i saw i saw hulk hogan there once
uh and jake this nick roberts and a
bunch of other guys like i went there a
long time
my sister went to college right by there
like i know these people that were there
these are good americans nobody
literally nobody in that stadium was
singing the national anthem because it
had anything to do with racism
and i think that if we're going to take
this stuff back it's not just
you know we got to do it locally and in
our family as we as we always talk about
here
and i think really is the the first key
to the answer the other key to the
answer is
like be proud like actually be proud
and and fight for this country while we
still have a chance to fight
and i hope that at every sporting event
uh if people you know if the athletes
the millionaire athletes who get to play
a sport for a living which any of us in
our right mind would love to like play a
game that we love and get paid millions
of dollars to do
if they want to kneel because of this
unjust nation well then they can kneel
and the
and the owners can decide whether they
want those players on their teams
and and that's the beauty of freedom and
free markets
but i think for all of us that love this
country man when you go to a public
event and they sing the national anthem
sing the freaking national anthem fly a
flag
uh you know whatever it is that you
could do in your life because this
amazing precious thing uh it shouldn't
this is this is the point it shouldn't
cause tingles up your spine
uh to hear the national anthem song
because for
generations we would hear the national
anthem song and it didn't seem
maybe it didn't seem that important
that's not quite the quite right way to
say it
it was always important but now the
freedom
that's behind that song and those words
feels tenuous right it feels like we're
giving it away and then it's just
or it's slipping away or it's being
taken away so be like those people
i love you long island i'm telling you i
was so proud
proud to to be from long island and like
i was looking at the people in the
crowds like i know those people
those are my people those are good
people and those are your people if
you're proud of america too so don't be
like
the new york times op-ed writers and
don't be like msnbc hosts and don't be
like these
these charlatans who are pushing
critical race theory and equity
and marxism and the destruction of
america on all of us
be better and it ain't that hard because
they're pretty terrible
on that note guys uh have a great
weekend everybody i've i've got a few
more interviews today
we're pre-taping a little bit because i
am going to be in miami
next week uh for about five days i'm
interviewing uh
mayor francis suarez who is the
phenomenal mayor
of miami who is just transforming that
city into a tech hub
and i have a bunch of meetings about uh
locals we got a lot cooking there i'm
really
excited about i think we'll do a a
locals meet up so if you want to
actually meet me and have a drink in
florida reubenreport.locals.com
all right have a great week everybody
fly that flag that freak flag the
american flag all the flags
but not that crazy gay rainbow flag it's
just awful they added the brown and the
pink and it's just it's they ruined the
rainbow they actually ruined the rainbow
american flag much better than that
other flag all right have a good weekend
everybody